THE NASDAQ FINISHED AHEAD 181.
LET'S GET ANALYSIS FROM CHARLES
PAYNE FOX BUSINESS.
CHARLES, GREAT TO SEE YOU.
YOU LISTENED TO THE PRESIDENT
TODAY, YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> YEAH, I WATCHED THE WHOLE
THING.
I WAS SOMEWHAT FRUSTRATED, BRET,
THIS IS A SERIOUS ISSUE.
CAN YOU TELL AMERICANS DON'T
BELIEVE YOUR EYES OR YOUR
POCKETBOOKS AND I DON'T THINK
THESE KIND OF EVENTS HELP.
I WATCHED THE ENTIRE THING.
IT WAS MOSTLY HEY BRAGGING
SESSION ABOUT, YOU KNOW, IT
BEING -- THESE THINGS NOT
HAPPENING BEFORE CHRISTMAS.
THIS SUPPLY CHAIN ISSUE IS GOING
TO GO ON FOR A LONG TIME.
THERE ARE SHORT-TERM REASONS FOR
IT BUT ALSO LONG-TERM REASONS
FOR IT I THINK THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING TO UNDERSTAND IS
THAT THE AVERAGE AMERICAN IS
SUFFERING MIGHTILY.
IT'S NOT ABOUT THE CHRISTMAS
PRESENTS PEOPLE MAY OR MAY NOT
HAVE GOTTEN.
I'M WAITING ON FEW THINGS,
INCLUDING SOME AIR HOCKEY TABLES
I DON'T THINK WILL MAKE IT.
BUT THE POINT IS, YOU KNOW,
THESE SESSIONS SHOULD BE
DESIGNED TO SEEK SOLUTIONS, YOU
KNOW, AND EVERY TIME THEY TURN
INTO SOME SORT OF CHEERLEADING
HEY LOOK WHAT WE DID KIND OF
THING.
AND IT DOESN'T HELP.
IT DOESN'T SOLVE THE PROBLEMS
AND IT CERTAINLY DOESN'T HELP.
PUBLIC IMAGE.
WE DO HAVE SOME SERIOUS PROBLEMS
WITH SUPPLY CHAINS AND SOME OF
THEM ARE GOING TO GO AWAY
NATURALLY.
LISTEN, THE LAST STIMULUS CHECKS
HAVE GONE OUT.
THAT IS ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
CREATED DEMAND.
WHEN ALL THAT DEMAND CAME UP.
EVERYONE WENT TO THE COMPUTERS
AND HIT A FEW BUTTONS BOTTOM A
LOT OF STUFF AND PUT THEM ON
SHIPS FROM CHINA.
PROBLEM CONTAINERS ECONOMIC
RELATIONSHIP WITH CHINA, WHEN
SHIPS LEAVE HERE, THEY DON'T
HAVE THAT MANY CONTAINERS ON
THEM BECAUSE CHINA IS NOT BUYING
OUR PRODUCTS.
SO THEY CHARGE SO MUCH MORE OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL MONTHS IT'S
BEEN TWO, THREE, FOUR TIMES AS
MUCH TO SHIP SOMETHING HERE TO
THERE GUESS WHO PACE THE PRICE?
WE DO.
THERE ARE SOME THINGS IN THERE
SOME OF THE CEOS WERE PRETTY
COOL, PRESS SMITH OHIO LOVE IF
YOU EVER GET A CHANCE LOOK AT
HIS COLLEGE ON FEDEX THAT HE GOT
A C ON.
BUT, YOU KNOW, I WAS HOPING FOR
MORE OF A SOLUTIONS ORIENTED
CONVERSATION.
>> Bret: YEAH.
SO, IF YOU ARE TELLING SOMEBODY
AT A HOLIDAY PARTY OR JUST
SOMEBODY THAT YOU ARE MEETING
WITH WHAT'S THE STATE OF THE
ECONOMY AS WE ARE HEADING INTO
2022.
WHAT DO YOU, CHARLES PAYNE SAY?
>> I THINK THE ECONOMY IS GOOD.
BUT, I AM WORRIED ABOUT SOME OF
THE SIGNS AHEAD.
SOME OF THE INTERESTING THINGS
AHEAD.
LISTEN, WE CAME INTO 2021.
WE CAME INTO THIS YEAR IN
AMAZING SHAPE.
HOUSEHOLD BALANCE SHEETS
STRONGER THAN EVER BEEN.
WE SENT OUT TRILLIONS OF
DOLLARS.
PEOPLE PAID OFF DEBT, BOUGHT
STUFF AND PUT SOME IN THE BANK.
HOUSEHOLD BALANCE SHEETS.
THE ABILITY TO SPEND MONEY AFTER
YOU HAVE PAID YOUR BILLS NEVER,
NEVER BEEN BETTER.
SAME THING WITH CORPORATE
BALANCE SHEETS AND WE HAD A
VACCINE.
I THINK WE ARE GOING TO BE
SLOWER NEXT YEAR.
I'M CONCERNED, I'M TO BE QUITE
FRANK WITH YOU I'M HAPPY THAT
THIS BUILD BACK BETTER HAS
PAUSED AND MAYBE WON'T GO
THROUGH.
I THINK IT WOULD HAVE BEEN MORE
OF A PROBLEM IN TERMS OF THIS
INFLATION CRISIS, WHICH IS THE
NUMBER ONE CRISIS IN THIS
COUNTRY.
SO, YEAH, YOU KNOW WHAT?
THE ECONOMY WILL SLOW.
HOPEFULLY IN.
I LIKE THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN
BROUGHT UP SMALL BUSINESSES OR
SMALL BUSINESS APPLICATIONS
THAT'S THE ETHOS OF AMERICA.
PULLING YOURSELF UP BY THE BOOT
STRAPS.
IT BEGAN LAST YEAR.
IT'S CONTINUING THIS YEAR.
AND MAKES ME VERY HOPEFUL.
PARTICULARLY YOUNG MILLENNIALS
AND GENERAL ZERS ARE GOING OUT
THERE AND MAKING IT HAPPEN.
>> Bret: LET'S HOPE FOR A GOOD